you have to be
forget that no you're here for possibly
a porno
yeah I mean you were having us sit on a
bed and there's lights and cameras we're
not sure what we're here for
maybe we're here to try out sleeping mat
when someone tells me to lay down on the
bed that's exactly what I do
Oh surprise I like some kindest
surprises make me really nervous
Wow present it's a box it's a beautiful
box
[Music]
one two three
I'm gonna go ahead and say this is not a
back scratcher this is a when they come
a night after a long day of where it's a
little loud
like if you try to get Street you got
there like three blankets above the
phone it has this been any wizard should
I be touching yeah I would say it costs
maybe 199 five dollars no I think a
hundred seventy I'm gonna say $8,000
8008 thousand seven to eight thousand
dollars is gonna be really depressed
um fifty five hundred five hundred
dollars maybe definitely more than that
maybe like a thousand good weight good
weight nice like little shape and see my
shape this thing cost like eleven
hundred and $99 oh my god who would buy
this Ivanka Trump okay so how much does
this actually cause 15 grams no way we
it costs $15,000 50 you I want it if it
spending so much for your roommates here
you masturbate you gotta treat yourself
like if you see everybody with like gold
watches you're just like you know what
that guy he's got something going on I
could see myself buying one with my home
and then just so I show it off the girls
that come to my apartment way Hey I
would be so afraid that I would break it
or lose it
oh this better have a three-speed
like oh yeah a three at least I also
expected to make pizza give you that
they orgasm infinitely for the rest of
your life I mean who would buy a go
vibrator I mean you don't say that's
true Paris Hilton Paris Hilton Lisa
Vanderpump
Rihanna Taylor Swift with that right
under her bed Gwyneth Paltrow and she
would probably recommend it to people on
goop it's like this affordable vibrator
what about in catania $1,000 mother
because she's on another plane